envie de revoir comme le poteau et
cetera au parcours du combattant on a
envie de les voir et les cadres et des
candidats qui en bavent sur la question
sans tache malaria il ya tout il ya la
stratégie et d'émotion photo alors c'est
une super épreuve mais ça n'a aucun
intérêt ça vous dit de rester 32 35
minutes devant devant de personnes
debout sur un poteau voiture tu as bien
deux heures sur une toile
[Applaudissements]
oh
jean-michel moi c'est un beauf dubitatif
parce que j'attende j'attends de voir
parce que benjamin comme tous les
animateurs il a quand même année go qui
est assez important comme tout le monde
comme ça car bien sûr donc un ego encore
plus grand et c'est pas évident de se
mettre dans la passe d'un chroniqueur
rouler un peu à votre service comm mah
comme danger réussi juillet je parlais
des grands animateurs
ça montre l'auteur
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
si vous aviez voix je sais que vous êtes
tous très riche
voilà donc votre héritage si vous ne
deviez le donner à quelqu'un demande
d'agir autour de la table le plus
important je demanderai à julian dernier
c'est quand même celui qu'on attend tous
voilà valérie bénaïm à qu'elle bat
monfils évidemment mais ici la règle
franchement je suis obligé huawei mais
c'est pourquoi en fout du pognon les
noms mais je ne sera pas ou quoi
il a une famille nombreuse il ad des
gens à charge
il faut l'aider à wave ou au chant je
donnerai un cas plus parce qu'elle est
jeune a la vie devant elle
jean-mi agent lui pour qu'il se paye un
auteur pour ses spectacles
oui pitié ne nous obligez pas regarder
la semaine prochaine même pour le boulot
et quant à christophe beaugrand l'atout
humour de l'émission c'est comme si on
faisait que gilles verdez l'atout
sensualité d'une soirée gala
[Applaudissements]
2 cette fois que tous les attaques sur
son temps dans la catégorie pire vannes
jean michel maire est ce que vous êtes
déjà fait vraiment draguer à fond sur un
plateau moi oui et clio chanteur s'est
même pas son nom et chanter quoi
gilbert montagné est pourquoi tschiember
dire une connerie pareille je ne sais
pas il a flashé sur mes doigts mais tu
sais
[Applaudissements]
la firme de l'année de la tribu a quitté
le gagnant est
jean michel maire
[Applaudissements]
ah bon